citizens of the reject Nation it is time to go to
War World War II Justice Society Justice League
World War II which is it I don't know but I'm
excited have you seen this too I have not Coy
I feel like every so often there's an entire
surge of new people that are like why are
they re-watching these and I gotta say hey not
it's a First Time Warner never seen him we're
approaching like 30 of these I know it's trippy
man pretty exciting we're powering through a
journey together we almost like we've been to
war war videos of the DC Universe at least a
couple times we've seen a lot of continuities
a lot of Hawkman not talking today that might
change maybe he'll speak a little bit more than
Black Bolt we'll find out leave in the comments
below what you want us to watch next we have
begun our tomorrow verse Journey also always
remember to hit that notification Bell to find out
when we got more of these and like subscribe share
this with your friends so we can keep making more
of these because that's how it works and we also
want to thank prepper for editing the reaction
because without them it's a lot of us staring
at a screen and that's not nearly as fun or is
it thank you prepper for making us look good
without further Ado I want to remind you to also
become a patron too then you can watch this entire
experience front to back beginning to end with our
resting faces we're very very pensive but engaged
that's how we rest and watch that's obviously
everybody knows uh I think that's gonna do it
because we've we've been to wakan we've had a
bat verse shirt and now we go to war in three two
[Applause]
Mr President already we have to act now it's
kind of like driving yeah through the city
they've taken control of most of Europe and Russia
it's an invasion he's been searching for ancient
artifacts of course you'll mean magical artifacts
Auto Maniac unless of course he's right I mean
both can be true yes let me introduce you to the
team rex Tyler known as our man now he's developed
a chemical called meraklow to enhance speed
strength everything an hour at a time damn Lance
a bit of a fire brain with Sonic sound abilities
that have gotten her shunned by her community
she's just fully World War II Black Canary
obtaining his powers of speed Jay Garrick has been
a full-time crime fighter Carter Hall an ancient
Egyptian in a modern Egyptian's body claims
this is his uh fourth reincarnation who will lead
this Motley Crew I think I've got someone in mind
yes I thought that was Steve Trevor what do you
say Mr President are you ready to end this war
yes I love it love the old school Vibes
I like when they commit to a choice
um at Bomer oh yeah like commitment is so
key when you're making something like this
it is society that makes more sense for World
War II but I wasn't certain I don't want to
be wrong so I went with both it makes sense
it's Society gets to know societies versus
leagues everything that's just it's a simple
job somebody's got to do it makes more sense
canonically but then again Wonder Woman
being part of the Justice it's fine it's
fine according to the trajectory of the sun
we should have the max amount of light if we
set the blanket here get a little shade
it's gonna be a hot damn Metropolis oh
[Music]
do you think it might rain I can
grab an umbrella just in case just
you wanted to get out of town away from my other
job what do you want from me is this just a fling
because no no Iris it's okay if it is but I'm
not interested oh I love you the best way to
keep you safe is by making sure no one finds out
if you really believe that then break up with me
oh I'll make it up to you
tomorrow a hundred sandwiches
but it is illogical not if you're Superman [Music]
tickle them is he immune to tickling
cool shot nice oh geez this is well animated I'm
enjoying the POV stuff help with the tentacles
yes
oh
accelerating projectiles oh damn it oh [Music]
recalibration success at 99 it's gonna
be so annoying to fight this guy yeah
never tell me the odds
[Music]
the speed force
[Music] that Dr Fate yeah how and why
I don't yet know cool so you end up
back in World War II [Music] would
not want to fight her nope oh yeah
damn they made her especially
fast yeah that's awesome
ricochet
bouncing dudes off the fights in this
is awesome yeah consistently oh yeah
geez this must have come out after Wonder Woman
yeah yeah the movie there's a lot of mirroring
I keep expecting to hear the whole thing yeah
right my chunky XL where are you ah right on time
kind of crazy
did president Roosevelt send you
what's happening keep an eye on
whatever this is am I dead this is the afterlife
Nazis
yep now's your chance Barry Bonk bunk
oh dang
awesome
dang that was amazing speed slapping Nazi I'm from
the future it's not impossible
I mean with the speed force
we got is it Tom Hardy up
there don't show his face yeah
Steve Steve yeah yeah ah you can't you
hurt States oh no I really just say
trajectory the velocity hawkman's
wingspan he won't make it no damn
cheese good povs in this movie yeah
the lockout shots and povs are amazing
now back into the speed force
what if the oxygen is different I
wonder why he's having trouble breathing
oh there you go
teamwork boy I see you picked up another
Playmate it seems I misjudged you thank
you seems that I also look past
your very similar costume to our
own flag this this gentleman with
the similar symbol on his chest
hourman you and J with me on the ground Carter
you and Dinah take the sky and I can do nothing if
I've been that movie oh yeah
[Music] love the teamwork little teamwork Beats
nice awesome that's great [Music]
oh no not the pawn shops not the bond intro
Oh I thought I said shiza for a second [__]
it's the Battle Cry Future Boy this is Shakespeare
a war correspondent do I know you this is Howard
Stark also Billy Shakespeare yeah Billy shakes
the real sugar I can't hold this in anymore
will you marry me attempt Trevor oh oh ouch
he proposes every day and every day she says
no didn't take you for a stalker [Music] you've
got a new Mission we can't decode the Intel the
Germans are looking for a new artifact they're
saying it's a game changer oh no a man with
mystical abilities they pulled him out of their
camps and stuck him in a securely guarded Castle
in Bavaria they say he can break any code problem
is he's insane what are we gonna do about him he
should stick with us for research ah I'm really
curious how if this is part of that tomorrow
verse how this all ties in with like flash not
knowing the Justice League obviously Batman was
separate and Superman was separate maybe we'll
culminate in a big old League finally was that
the voice of the same Superman that's a good
question yeah I feel like but I'm not 100 okay
wow Castle Wolfenstein let's move out
the slide every time
nice dude nice if this goes
Haywire blame The New Guy
sharing the speed force and all that
is interesting with time travel no
throw that plate at him or the whole table
or yeah he said she would come this is yours
supposed to give this to you who's who sent
you you have to make sure it never happens oh
no oh no Shakespeare
Ah that's why I look familiar to flash
yeah and if the curl is these straight
lines I didn't recognize them the
mustache clever it's the same actor
Coy oh clearly the voice actor that
I've been not hearing this all time
hey what did they do to you no it's it's
can oof I know him from a previous life
well make him snap out of it we're
not equipped to handle it they're all
dead oh we need your help my
friend can you translate this
oh
wow
it's Clark ah it's Clark Kent interesting you're
Superman it's me flash how did you get here did
you follow me through that time work is this a
rescue why do you have a mustache you're one of
the most selfless people I know I don't know
you in my time on this planet I learned you
look out for yourself and journalism in my time
something's different what about your parents
Martha and Jonathan Kent died in an accident when
I was three years old I was sent to an orphanage
oh dang what do they teach you there I'm not
in the past this isn't a different time whoa
this is a different earth oh no crises on more
Earths there's so many crises and so many Earths
that makes more sense for continuity Yeah
by not making sense for continuity yep
coordinates no he's not ready yet just
know what it means huh you arguing about
Superman for please do you know a way for
me to get back home back to my universe but this
would be Earth One the real Earth you may return
but you have another task ahead of you and a
lesson human no I won't tell him about the league
regenerate to maybe three ships above
us do they know we're here we're about
to find out since the Justice
society's official submarine crew
that just thinks of battleships
no
flooding ugh
nice man Jenner the Justice Society we we have to
surface is there any way to restart the engines
you have an extra 20 batteries lying around I got
a couple flashes there she is what
now no subs took batteries yeah
oh yeah
sweet well I'll be I'm learning so many new
things I could do with my power I'm a brand new
Flash lock this behind me and flood the tube
torpedo woman you are just so beautiful when
you're about to kick some Nazi tail you know there
is a captain on board let me make an honest Amazon
come on come on that was a good one both of
you climbing the tube he's good at proposing
go
oh bad
cool nice it's raining depth charges D3 D4
you suck my battles good job Wonder Woman
oh no who These Guys these related to
Brainiac somehow they've they got that vibe
they got red eyes can't trusted pull over
what has happened
oh dang maybe they can be trusted
with their red eyes so is Atlantis
in the Bermuda Triangle that would make
sense that's why all those disappearances
wow cool this is so like sprawling it's exciting
because I don't know any of this cannon so it's
like all new yeah I'm loving this I'm Arthur
ruler of Atlantis in all of the oceans of this
world why should I care about the Affairs
of those above because these Nazis will not
stop until the whole world is theirs above and
below as above I think you speak true daughter
of a politer I will help you there is something
I have that might turn the tide in your favor ah
the tide the tide it's an ocean pun he's
got puns the king of Atlantis made a pun
yes I see nothing quite ah damn it betrayal
why Aquaman why Aqua Nazi plenty and Magic is
quite powerful these they're trying to escape
Heil Hitler oh no Aqua Nazi a storm destroyed
my ship and the atlanteans saved me little know
that my particular talents would grant me control
of their King oh you set us up the war is all but
over and you have lost enjoy the Solitude of this
prison oh it's time to show those above what true
power looks like should make his mustache shadow
just a little more bring it in a little bit I
mean he does look like the Aryan he is pretty
much the ideal blonde blue eyes should have known
although if we can somehow combine our energy we
might regain full power how will that bypass magic
physics are Universal Diana when I was younger I
could vibrate between molecules seriously
you can do that what the heck have I been
doing all these years I love the back and forth
teaching each other how to flash [Music] foreign
that was fantastic that was beautiful
physical comedy one of the guards said
the king Aqua Man is headed down to the trench
he's going to unlock some sort of cage what's
in the cage a spin-off movie it would have
been a Black Manta movie we would have liked
it yeah they're also committed to this sort of
Classic Hollywood lighting yeah you know very
much of the era lighting yeah that like
three-point like nose Loop kind of thing
talking to the Shell who knows
what might happen what does this do
plantian pressure
use your Trident to focus
your call unlock the gate
bring the creatures seal our Victory locked Gates
[Music]
sweet oh yeah come on flash wake him up
not so special without your
suit yeah crappy name or
I'm strong don't worry get your fill
of violence jeez [Music] wake up
let's go no something is wrong
oh they got a power player [Music]
oh Legends of the Hidden Temple
yes it's the Elder gods are angry God
no
atlanteans always invading
beaches wow we got hover tanks
how about a real fight
how's that for some sonar
got a perfect view from the balcony hon
let's watch the end of the world join the
Army and fight Nazis fall in love with
an Amazonian princess and end up in an
atlantian tank taking on bad guys Steve
Trevor never complained about being bored
again it was all in the pamphlet man you knew
what you were signing up for they warned you
yeah it's like a shark and a stingray combined
there it is ugh
call Charlie Hunnam in the mech suits where's the
Pacific Rim team some Yeagers
in here we need the Yeagers
you know who we haven't seen in
a while at Shakespeare fellow oh
no nah he's back home writing news
stories man typing away I gotta come
back couldn't help foreshadowing
there no no no no suit to pay off
these two [Music] my hero oh no no Hawk man
you did so much [__] that's the price we
pay for dialogue this last moment of
saving her and never talking again
incarnate promise me you won't give up on this on
life oh on love Yeah remember it's the only thing
worth living for no save him with true love's kiss
I'm coming oh
oh buddy
time to go ham mer unleash it Canary yes oh no
no crab monster
nice nice man
get it in the mouth Through The Eyes hey come
on it's like one of those video game bosses yes
sorry hey we
don't America oh
yeah Steve
Dang
if you Bonk him hard enough
on the head keep bonking
cool oh
my face
you called that a scream
yes oh
peel flesh from bone
oh my God
she just skin that street shark
meanwhile in the crab fight a little
help over here crap battle perfect
bowling pretty tough on the outside
taking Pac-Man and then boom
oh my God it was so metal so nth metal rest in
peace yeah Steve God see Trevor's the coolest
no I admire your bravery but your fate will
be like the rest you have no
business fighting with gods
take it back oh you're about to get
junkie excelled dude yes thank you [Music]
once the key here
[Music]
yeah no you you did this you should
yeah that's your dog I
should probably call him back
hey I'm sorry I didn't mean to yeah oh
foreign
just following orders it's all good it's
all good everybody you think this means
you've won you and your league Society it's a
society man the sound of failure you're just
a dude yeah man because he's got psychic
powers he's not just a dude but he needs
mcguffins and stuff he's like the real Hitler
he's not even as great as his master wraith no
no what oh damn it [Music] yes you okay I'll
be fine uh did he miss every major organ each
we have to do something we might not have to look
there he is Shakespeare there he is does he
have a mustache is this the Justice League
he shaved CGI shaved that's true yeah if you
look at his upper lip it's real distorted [Music]
the Uber man shaved were you just a reporter
I was am but I couldn't sit on the sidelines
any longer I guess it was time to get in the
game Oh I thought when the war was over we
tomorrow is never guaranteed only
today that's why we fight right
so what do you say Diana Grant
a dying man his final request oh
no no no no no
oh I wish I could stay but I've got a world
of my own that needs all the help I can get
oh you understood why I said no I was wrong oh
oh yeah
I had to give him a little push
wow
whoa double flashes oh
damn it's the moment he left in the oh
that was cool yeah Brainiac won't be the
last to show up and threaten our cities
our world but there are also others like
us if we stick together we can keep the
peace Fight For Truth the American way
hey they actually said it oh shoot I forgot
something glad some things haven't changed oh
I know we said that we could always have
tomorrow but whatever tomorrows I have
I want them to be with you Barry what
are you doing will you marry me yes oh
just the right sizes Wonder Woman [Music] oh
cute that was lovely cute
and Chris was Superman Matt Boomer I thought was
flash it was Darren Chris last time yeah Mercer
is our man hell yeah okay okay Liam McIntyre was
Aquaman so not a slowed down nope someone else
entirely that's weird you're like let's just drop
fill in an octave yeah oh man I love that I love
that I at nope and it's such linear writing but
at no point did I parallel the Steve Trevor Diana
relationship with his like that was the whole
point and I missed it which I love yeah yeah
no this had like this was so rich and it had so
many different elements because like you know the
World War II threat is obviously very vital and
very sort of Snappy and engaged but everybody's
got a bit of a character story there's romance
to spare yeah and like actual you know not just
people falling in love but you know like there's
a lot there's backstory there's like weight yeah
like the whole Steve and Diana thing like was very
Charming but also came with like a heavy cost and
I'm curious actually because like you know the
the Wonder Woman portrayal here is very much you
know is is a war Warrior woman yeah a little more
stoic has a bit more stoicism a bit more Stern
didn't bother me like it did in the uh because
she's not not that yeah but at no point did she
feel like she was a warrior at the cost of her
good and that was my issue with the new 52 stuff
was yeah it felt like her being a warrior was like
a blunt object like where she was like speed yeah
whereas this is like this this is what I have to
do like like one of the last things she said was
like you know when this is over I wanted to see
it like that felt like that good was still there
yeah she had to be a warrior in times of War
as opposed to the other one where it was like
throw me at stuff I'm wrong let me add him let me
yeah like I don't like Scrappy do one Roman yeah
um so like this totally worked for me because
it was still her goodness and even though it
was accident like you know it was times of War she
was still under there yeah absolutely and I mean I
thought she it was cool to see her leading the
team I thought she made like a good I love the
thing with Shakespeare Superman and having to
you know sort of coax him in yeah and then the
alternate origin 2021 this is a reason so it was
well after the one room movie so well yeah and I
was wondering too during this if they changed up
her accent specifically to sort of Harkin to Gal
Gadot and I'm guessing in the tomorrow verse
there is no Steve Trevor as he is Canon Dead
uh so they definitely did the like you know time
travel element but in a different way but also it
was a different universe so I guess there could
be I guess yeah Wonder Woman what I was wondering
is that now I mean this certainly seems like
it's setting that up and and we know from long
Halloween that that is pretty you know isolated on
its own so we've had a Batman long Halloween we've
had a Superman introduction yeah and now we've got
Flash and Superman as a way to start the Justice
League yeah so I can imagine whatever's next
there will be like more present day Justice and
this was two years ago so I imagine this is like
the universe as it is now like whatever they're
making currently I guess so or or at least I don't
know if the tomorrow verse continues because they
just released a new movie recently it was like
something Batman Doom or something like that yeah
and then uh they've got another crisis movie on
the verge out soon yeah uh I think they're doing
yeah yeah but I mean I'm just curious if the
tomorrow verse you know keeps going or does it
end before we get to the present day because we're
closer 2021 this wasn't long ago yeah I mean we've
got at least a couple more in this continuity
I think at minimum but uh because the next one
in Canon would have been Batman following this
would be Batman okay so now so it went flash it
went Superman Flash found in the Justice League
but Batman was was mentioned in Superman yes and
now we're going to meet Superman in order and then
whatever's next yeah me Batman and then whatever's
next it's all going and especially for the second
installment to be like okay we're jumping into an
alternate dimension in there yeah yeah that
aren't going to appear as they appeared here
I thought it was cool because uh you know sitting
here and having seen various recently seen various
takes on uh Barry going back in time and changing
things with the speed force and all that stuff uh
like this was a really cool Twist on all that
that managed to hearken to those without being
oh we're doing another flash point but it's in
World War II yeah it was a flash point but in
a totally different way and it allowed for a
Wonder Woman to be in the second film without
it being like the Wonder Woman we might have
yeah totally and it's like I love that they had
Barry as our sort of eye line and I love that he
fits into the story whilst also sort of I don't
know still allowing like the rest of this Justice
Society to kind of have that Spotlight like he's
a really good sort of comic relief he's a good eye
line for us and it's really fun to watch him play
off of Jay Garrick but also like you know I feel
like you still get to have like the full brunt
of just the fun and excitement of seeing like the
Justice Society do their thing and yeah and this
particular team I thought was really nice because
it was cool to see our man I've never seen him
animated yeah like our man uh uh Canary uh Pacman
speaks Hawkman speaks and even he like I loved his
little uh the moments between him and uh Black
Canary you know and and her yeah that Bond there
was interesting yeah and that little subtle thing
of like maybe she'll take off you know she in in
a way that's never really is sort of like obvious
they sort of make her out to be sort of like the
most I did like that of the team and so yeah by
the end it seems like she more fully Embraces
it despite the loss of the moments of rudeness
with strange and like the also yeah that glance
I really liked I liked the use of of the invading
uh atlanteans like we've seen a few times before
but in this context it had that like storming
Normandy but storming Santa Monica yeah yeah
yeah but it works for the story really well yeah
I mean it works in terms of iconography because
obviously blonde hair blue eyed Arthur Curry but
yeah but that sure is Nazi yeah but then having
you know that little piece of of you know almost
Indiana jones-esque historical fiction of like the
Nazis are always looking for these artifacts
and stuff and they're always looking for like
a cultish magical ways to help their efforts
and what do they do they found the atlanteans
and sort of brainwashed their whole Fleet and the
torture elements were very much like what we know
of the horrors of the Nazis and I like that like
they might have taken you know Dr Fate uh sorry
um no Dr Fate I said strange earlier and I knew it
was wrong and then I corrected myself and it felt
wrong twice I knew it was fate don't don't at me
uh but doctor we gotta get you back to your right
time Coy what Universe am I in uh but Dr Fate
being someone that would have like an artifact and
like someone they would torture for information
like that all felt very appropriate to the horrors
of what they built here yeah and uh you know if if
you saw my Superman video there's a lot of Jewish
iconography in Superman because he was invented
by a pair of Jewish creators who were coping with
the horrors of the time and that's why I've always
liked the like Superman versus the clan comic and
like certain elements of like you know him fight
Nazis is a lot like Captain America fighting Nazis
for me it feels like this is the way it should
be so him him coming back then to take down all
those planes and stuff was like yeah yeah it was a
great and and like a lot of really great like this
also felt like a war movie and it had multiple
sequences that hearken to different aspects of
different war movies you have your stuff like out
on you know these crumbling European cities and
things like that and you're sort of no man's land
type of you know like grounded Warfare moments
then you have Naval like submarine and boat
battles then you have aerial battles and then
you get creatures and stuff like that but this
sort of ran the gamut of all the different sort of
places we had to fight in the land in the air of
the sea and then you know you're you're raiding
this Castle which has like a sort of Doom almost
like wolf and stuff like less you know crazy heavy
metal creatures or zombies but you know it still
has that sort of like Wolfenstein exploitationy
kind of feel about it and uh and the action I
thought was the actual really so well shot so well
shot and captured and like that yeah I know well
I mean that's the thing I mean like it it still
is you're still figuring out lighting they're
figuring out frames angles movement blocking the
camera like this was forgive the pun but it was so
Punchy and it had so much energy and flavor yeah I
really think this was one of the more specific
ones they made choices and they committed and
they decided the theme and the tone and they like
engaged with the audience the whole time and they
still did it while having all these characters
get their time in the sun it didn't feel like
the setting took over the characters but it felt
like they adjusted the characters accordingly in
a way that was really on brand yeah I really liked
this one this was really special this was a lot of
fun yeah no I loved the I loved the combination of
getting yeah all the range of heroism and sci-fi
that you want out of your DC characters but also a
truly committed throwback to the World War II era
hope Constantine's in the tomorrow verse because
now at this point I love it they've given us a
really cool second movie Swing so I'm really we
don't know what's coming so it's really exciting
to see like this is not something I would expect
as a second movie so I'm really curious what the
tomorrow verse becomes yeah because that means
they did a Superman movie to launch a elseworld
and then a two harder Batman yeah what a crazy
journal what is the pacing let's just go let's
just do whatever yeah so will I chase our wildest
so far I'm hitting I like yeah I mean I've Loved
uh this tomorrow verse Journey thus far and
I mean certainly the Batman long Halloween's
have their own batmany kind of isolated quality
they certainly seem like they work on their own
but this especially the way this in those brief
uh prologue and epilogue moments tied into the
current timeline and and Barry disappearing
right before catching the bullet coming back
right behind him so cool so great and and yeah
like even though it I feel like it would have
felt more random if we were only in the past and
never had this little piece were really nice yeah
yeah that worked I I love this especially as a
Flashpoint story I like I knew when we watched
we started this with Flashpoint I knew I liked
Flashpoint stories I did not know this would be
one and how much I'd love it so I officially
love Flashpoint stories because that was a
really special way to tell that yeah I I loved
kind of every layer this was going for really
yeah good humor good personality good everything
and the specificity keep making specific stuff
if you've got archetypal characters you make
a specific story because you've got the trust
of the audience in the characters make more stuff
like this DC this was awesome come on let us know
in the comments uh I did not look this one up to
see if people loved it or hated it a lot of times
we watch these and everybody's like well that was
the worst thing ever so uh it's really cool to see
like without knowing that like the the people's
opinion and then now I'm gonna look up to people's
opinion but uh let's get a patron of the day
shout out before we Boogie on out of here we got
patron of the day shout out to Garth McMurray
this gentleman would you love a Superman this
gentleman must have loved the Shakespearean
twist this gentleman must have quite enjoyed
the way it was handled and ended and I feel
like ardenberry also as an else World guy oh
sure uh so I feel like this was like uh the
right one I feel like this the right Patron
to shout out as we begin the sales World Journey
uh Garth we appreciate your Justice your league
your society and your love the American way uh
much appreciated Arthur Murray as ever because
uh yeah this this feels like your cup of tea
so hopefully you've seen this one hopefully
you've seen us talking about you here and
if you haven't seen this one you should go
watch this one yeah you shouldn't have seen it
without I mean it wouldn't have made sense to
watch us watch it pieces hopefully I've seen
it but we thank you very much Garth McMurray
you super sexy reject much much appreciated you
let us know also what you want us to watch next
because yeah I've been I'm enjoying the hell
out of these much love y'all that is going to
do it for this episode of John and koi watch
stuff they've never seen seen before and quite
enjoy it yeah tune in next time as we discover
where the tomorrow verse goes but I assume and
that what a swing so far I've been digging
it we'll see you soon much love peace myself
[Music]